und jetzt das heute journal mit anna
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend in allen es kann
hinterher niemand sagen wir hätten es
nicht gewusst wir hätten es nicht kommen
sehen das wichtigste exportgut der
ukraine steckt fest weil russland die
zufahrt in ukrainische häfen abriegelt
weizen mais ölsamen die grundlagen für
die ernährung von millionen menschen
gerade in armen teilen dieser welt sind
blockiert wenn nichts passiert da sind
sich die experten einig droht die
schwerste hungersnot seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg
deshalb muss etwas passieren der krieg
gegen die ukraine wird auch zum getreide
krieg gegen die welt andreas künast
das video zeigt lastwagen einen endlosen
konvoi gekennzeichnet mit dem buchstaben
z nach angaben ukrainischer medien ist
es in mariupol gedreht und dokumentiert
wie russland getreide aus der ukraine
heraus schafft und auf die krim
transportiert es wäre ein beispiellos
groß angelegter diebstahl es wäre ein
weiterer beleg für das was deutschlands
außenministerin den korn krieg nennt und
eine bewusste kriegsstrategie des
russischen präsidenten putin weil er
gezielt gerade mit blick auf das
getreide die kornkammer in der ukraine
zerstört felder bombardiert lieferwege
in schutt und asche legt und den hafen
die häfen aus denen das getreide
ausgefahren werden könnte bewusst
blockiert seit russland die ukrainischen
helfen blockiert von mario pohl bis
odessa verwehrt putins kriegsmarine
57 mit getreide beladenen schiffen das
auslaufen an bord 1,25 millionen tonnen
weizen die ganze welt muss beunruhigt
seien vom deutschen vorsitz aus
alarmiert außenministerin berbalk letzte
woche die g7 außenminister und
entwicklungsministerin schulze heute die
g 7 quick lungs minister wenn ihr nichts
tun droht die schwerste hungersnot seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg vor dem krieg hat
die ukraine jeden monat bis zu sechs
millionen tonnen getreide und ölsamen
exportiert durch russlands blockade
hindurch schaffen es nur 200.000 tonnen
das ist ein schlag nicht nur für die
ukraine ohne unsere getreideexporte
herrscht bereits jetzt in dutzenden
ländern nahrungsmittelknappheit und mit
der zeit kann die lage ehrlich gesagt
schrecklich werden
zu allem unglück kommt zur blockade der
ukrainischen häfen dass indien wegen der
hitzewelle den weizenexport verbietet
dass die dürre in ostafrika die
schlimmste seit jahrzehnten ist und dass
russland nicht nur getreide stiehlt
sondern auch die verantwortung und die
schuld an hunger und not im westen gibt
es
sind die sanktionen die diese globale
krise produzieren und ihre urheber die
geleitet werden von aufgeblähten
ambitionen von homophobie
derwesten sucht auswege für das
ukrainische getreide binnenschiffers
wege zum beispiel ins baltikum oder die
geografisch naheliegendste lösung
schienenwege nach rumänien die brücke
alleine also die brücke über die züge
alleine wird aber nicht reichen weil wir
einfach die mengen die wir brauchen und
die die ukraine jahr liefern kann nicht
alleine über züge sozusagen
der werksteil in cannes vor 15 minuten
kommt aussenministerin berbalk in new
york an die getreide krise hat die
vereinten nationen erreicht es geht um
das leben von millionen menschen
interessant übrigens auch dass ein land
gerade für seine ausfuhren von stark
gestiegenen preis für weizen profitiert
und das ist russland
auf ein baldiges willkommen schwedens
und finnlands wir stehen füreinander
sagt die bundesministerin heute
deutschland hat im rekordtempo den weg
frei gemacht für eine zeitenwende beim
westlichen verteidigungsbündnis die
aufnahme von schweden und finnland soll
jetzt möglichst schnell klappen die
anderen 29 nato-staaten müssen auch
zustimmen probleme gibt es mit einem die
türkei blockiert ihr außenminister ist
heute bei seinem amtskollegen in den usa
weil letzterer herausfinden will was
genau die türkei tatsächlich will die
nordische nato expansion stoppen oder
vielleicht eher einen eigenen deal
machen und den eigenen wählern
imponieren und zweitens weil den usa das
nato problem jetzt äußerst ungelegen
kommt wir bringen unsere korrespondenten
mit dazu zunächst in die usa zur el mati
wissen immer wie hat man diese gespräche
denn sich jetzt atmosphärisch
vorzustellen
ja es wirkt er sehr freundlich auf uns
das was wir gesehen haben der türkische
außenminister mit seinem amerikanischen
amtskollegen hier mann war auf vornamen
basis toni und merfeld haben sie sich
genannt und der türkische außenminister
hat lage sagt dass man weiterhin den
grundsatz auch so sieht wie die usa
nämlich eine offene tür für jeden der
der nato beitreten will aber man hat
eben einerseits sicherheitsbedenken und
zum anderen hat hertha wo schule auch
noch
angemerkt dass schweden jahr
rüstungsgüter die lieferung dieser
rüstungsgüter eingestellt hatte vor
einigen jahren an die türkei also es war
so ein eindruck dass das sich
möglicherweise ein punkt anbahnt über
den mann dann reden kann es war sehr
freundlich und ich glaube es kam in
erster linie darauf an zu zeigen dass
man den bedenken der türkei sehr genau
zuhört heißt denn das auch wenn man es
ein bisschen weiter denkt dass die usa
eigentlich ziemlich zuversichtlich sind
dass diese türkische blockade am ende
gelöst werden kann
ja das sind sie weil sie glauben zu
wissen um was es eigentlich geht nämlich
die lieferung von modernisierungs
paketen für die f 16 kampfjets die die
türkei hat und möglicherweise darüber
hinaus auch noch die lieferung von 40
neuen kampfjets des typs f16 das wären
paket von sechs milliarden dollar das
würde sehr schwer fallen für joe biden
durch den amerikanischen kongress zu
bekommen deswegen ist das schwierig ich
glaube aber für die moderne
modernisierungs pakete gibt es spielraum
und wir haben auch vor in die
außenministerin aus deutschland hier
gefragt wie man das denn jetzt lösen
kann annalena baerbock sagte daraufhin
dass in dieser krise sollte jeder sehr
genau überlegen dass er seiner
verantwortung und wie er seiner
verantwortung gerecht werden kann ich
glaube dass in deutschland und in den
usa man davon ausgeht dass eine lösung
zu finden ist immer vielen dank dann
gucken wir noch weiter in die türkei
direkt ähnlichkeit zu jörg brase york
lassen sie uns noch ein bisschen über
die gründe reden offiziell ist die
türkei diese angebliche unterstützung
aus finnland und schweden für die kunden
ein dorn im auge ist das der wahre und
einzige grund
es gibt natürlich einige die sind der
meinung dass es auch innenpolitische
gründe gibt im nächsten jahr wird in der
türkei der präsident neu gewählt die
umfragewerte für präsident erdogan sind
natürlich wegen der wirtschaftlichen
lage wegen der desolaten lage im keller
und durch einen starken außenpolitischen
auftritt auftritt könnte er jetzt seine
islamisch konservative wählerschaft
natürlich mobilisieren aber ich denke
dass dieses argument oder diese
überlegungen zu kurz greift ich glaube
es geht der türkei tatsächlich darum
dass sie sich vom westen von der nato
von ihren partnern in ihren
sicherheitspolitischen bedenken nicht
ausreichend gewürdigt fühlt der kampf
gegen den pkk terrorismus ist in der
türkei staatsziel egal welche partei die
regierung stellt wird sie diesen kampf
fortsetzen wird dabei auch von der
mehrheit der bevölkerung unterstützt und
in diesem kampf fühlt man sich eben vom
westen nicht ausreichend unterstützt
ganz im gegenteil man fühlt sich sogar
dafür bestraft beispiel ist der
einmarsch der türkei in nordsyrien
2009/10 damals gegen die türkischen
militärs gegen die syrischen ableger der
pkk vor und die haben damals mit den usa
gekämpft gegen den dss gab daraufhin ein
waffenembargo das schweden zum beispiel
verhängt hat wir haben es gehört und
dieses land das angeblich bis heute
waschen an die epg liefert will jetzt in
die nato das konnte
von ankara nicht unwidersprochen
hingenommen werden jetzt unwidersprochen
hingenommen werden jetzt haben wir aus
den usa gerade gehört doch einiges an
zuversicht dass man da auch über diese
blockade wieder hinwegkommt wie sieht
das aus türkischer sicht aus wie ließe
sich denn die türkische regierung um
stimmen am ende
es wurde heute sowohl vom außenminister
ist auch vom berater von präsident
erdogan gesagt dass man wirklich
substantielle sicherheitsgarantien haben
will man will klare schritte sehen die
wirklich zeigen dass man die türkischen
bedenken ernst nimmt das können jetzt
mehrere punkte seien zum einen fordert
die türkei die auslieferung von 30
angeblichen terror unterstützer von
schweden man könnte auch verlangen dass
schweden eben das angesprochene
waffenembargo wieder aufhebt aber in
jedem falle glaube ich dass die türkei
sowohl von schweden als auch von
finnland ein eindeutiges bekenntnis dazu
haben will dass man in zukunft sehr viel
entschlossen als man das bisher getan
hat gegen die aktivitäten der pkk und
der epg in den jeweiligen ländern
vorgeht interessanter analyse herzlichen
dank auch in die türkei
unser nächstes thema es muss sich enorm
viel tun wenn europa die selbst
gesteckten ziele beim klimaschutz
erreichen will und als wäre das nicht
schon herausforderung genug kommt jetzt
ja noch dazu so schnell wie es geht
unabhängig zu werden von energie aus
russland die eu kommission hat heute
ihren plan dazu für die kommenden jahre
vorgelegt der ist milliardenschwer und
er spielt zu einem wichtigen teil auf
dem meer vor fast 40 jahren bestanden
die ersten deutschen windparks an land
wie hier in schleswig holstein aus
windrädern mit meist nur einer
durchschnittlichen leistung von jeweils
50 kilowatt moderne windräder im meer
schaffen 4000 das 80 fache sie sind
einerseits effizienter geworden aber
auch höher bis zu
260 meter hoch von der wasseroberfläche
bis zur spitze der rotorblätter denn
weiter oben weht der wind stärker und er
wird gleichmäßiger als am boden außerdem
sind weiter oben auch weniger vögel
unterwegs so ein einziges offshore
windrad kann dann bis zu 16.000
haushalte mit strom versorgen und den
braucht europa das offizielle motto aus
brüssel heißt
jedes windrad in der nordsee bedeutet
ein stück unabhängigkeit von wladimir
putin das ist eine der botschaften der
eu kommission heute und deshalb passt es
wunderbar in den kalender von kanzler
und kommissionspräsidentin dass die
dänische regierung zum wind gipfel nach
ezb- abgeladen hat die pläne die die eu
gleichzeitig in brüssel präsentiert sind
ehrgeizig statt wie geplant 40 sollen
künftig 45 prozent des europäischen
energiemixes aus erneuerbaren stammen
also ausbau der windkraft und eine
solardach pflicht ab 2026 für gewerblich
genutzte neubauten ab 29 auch für
privathäuser das alles kann nur
funktionieren wenn die genehmigungen für
windparks und solarflächen einfacher
werden im eu schnitt dauert es neun
jahre bis ein windrad strom liefert die
eu kommission meint auch berlin schnell
heißt natürlich dass es immer noch zwei
drei jahre dauert das ist die maximale
geschwindigkeit denn die anlagen müssen
der bestellt gefertigt hin kontrolliert
errichtet werden aber schneller als wir
im moment tun kann man es nicht machen
die beste energie ist ja immer noch die
idee eingespart wird sagt klima
kommissar franz zimmermann doch wie
gespart werden soll will er den
europäern nicht vorschreiben ein
tempolimit traute sich die kommission
nicht in den plan aufzunehmen dabei wäre
das die einfachste lösung findet
luxemburgs energieminister also von 130
auf 120 auf den europäischen autobahnen
das ist eine halbe million barrel und
dann zusammen mit zum beispiel zwei
tagen home office das ist noch mal eine
halbe million und damit könnte man auch
genug einsparen um einen druck nach
unten auf den ölpreis weltweit zu haben
und ich denke das würde wirklich nicht
schaden im dritten teil des pakets geht
es um energielieferungen jenseits von
russland die kommission schlägt den
gemeinsamen einkauf von flüssiggas und
wasserstoff vor ähnlich wie bei der
impfstoff beschaffen 300 milliarden euro
wird europa brauchen um die energiewende
zu finanzieren
das geld soll aus dem eu haushalt und
dem emissionshandel kommen zumindest
vorerst ob das reicht weiß auch der
klima kommissar nicht genau
es wird früher oder später einen moment
geben wo wir im europäischen maßstab auf
die finanzen schauen müssen so wie es
bei co wird auch war wir werden mit der
frage konfrontiert sein haben wir genug
geld um all das was wir tun wollen zu
finanzieren
auf dem wind gipfel in esbjerg
unterschreiben die niederlande
deutschland dänemark und belgien dass
sie ihre anstrengungen in sachen
windkraft künftig bündeln wollen die
botschaft aus brüssel ist hier
angekommen jetzt wird es darum gehen ob
die pläne der kommission auch im rest
europas auf zustimmung stoßen
und später im heute-journal update ein
ausführliches gespräch mit dem
technikvorstand des energieversorgers
ewe der sagt gerade deutschland habe
beim ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
kein erkenntnisproblem sondern ein
umsetzungsproblem das gleich heute
journal update nach ihr hier im zdf aber
erst hier bei uns johanna und da blicken
wir noch einmal auf die lage in der
ukraine
aus dem belagerten also stahlwerk in
mariupol sollen sich hunderte weitere
ukrainische kämpfer ergeben haben
genauso schicksal ist ungewiss laut pro
russischer separatisten hätten sich noch
weitere soldaten in dem stahlwerk auf
unterdessen läuft in kiew der erste
kriegsverbrecherprozess gegen einen
russischen soldaten der 21-jährige
angeklagte bekannte sich schuldig einen
unbewaffneten zivilisten erschossen zu
haben ihm droht eine lebenslange
haftstrafe
der klimawandel schreitet laut den
vereinten nationen weiter voran die
vergangenen sieben jahre waren die
wärmsten seit beginn der
meteorologischen aufzeichnungen das
steht im neuen klima bericht der
weltwetterorganisation
die konzentration von treibhausgasen in
der atmosphäre lag bereits 2020 um
149 prozent über dem vorindustriellen
niveau der meeresspiegel steigt
inzwischen um 4,5 mm pro jahr doppelt so
stark wie noch vor einigen jahren
außerdem wird das wasser der ozeane jahr
für jahr wärmer und sarah und kann
deshalb immer weniger zusätzliches co2
binden
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach hat
einen pandemieplan für den kommenden
herbst vorgestellt so sollen alle
bürgerinnen und bürger die möglichkeit
bekommen sich ein viertes mal gegen das
virus impfen zu lassen um das zu
ermöglichen will der bund zusätzliche
corona impfstoffe bestellen diese sollen
gegen verschiedene varianten wie delta
und omikron oder gegen eine kombination
mehrerer varianten wirken lauterbach
kündigte außerdem an dass die
impfzentren weiter bestehen bleiben
der bundestag ist aktuell so groß wie
nie zuvor um ihn deutlich zu verkleinern
haben abgeordnete der ampel koalition
jetzt einen neuen vorschlag für eine
wahlrechtsreform gemacht dieser sieht
vor dass die sogenannten überhang und
ausgleichsmandaten abgeschafft werden
sollen ein gewonnener wahlkreis wäre
dann also keine garantie mehr für einen
einzug in den bundestag
kritik an dem vorschlag kommt aus der
union die von der neuen regel
voraussichtlich besonders betroffen wäre
der csu-abgeordnete frieser sprach von
einer entwertung des wahlkreis gedankens
und der direkten elemente der demokratie
seit jahren ringen die parteien um eine
umfassende wahlrechtsreform die den
bundestag verkleinern soll
altkanzler gerhard schröder soll einem
antrag der ampel koalition zufolge einen
großteil seiner sonderrechte entzogen
werden etwa sein büro und seine
mitarbeiter zur begründung heißt es dass
schröder keine verpflichtungen aus dem
amt als ehemaliger bundeskanzler mehr
wahrnehme die kritik an schröder wächst
auch im europaparlament
in einem resolutionsentwurf wird
gefordert den altkanzler wegen seiner
verbindungen zur russischen
staatskonzernen auf die eu
sanktionsliste zu setzen morgen soll
darüber abgestimmt werden
manchmal muss man genau auf jedes wort
achten für gespräche mit der spd stehen
die grünen in nrw bereit mit dem
wahlsieger cdu dagegen reden sie heute
die grünen haben ihr nrw-ergebnis
vergangenen sonntag fast verdreifacht
aber für rot grün allein reicht das ja
ohnehin nicht schwarz-grün dagegen gab
es im industrieland nrw zwar noch nie
man kann das ganze aber wunderbar labeln
als kampf gegen die klimakrise verbunden
mit dem kampf für wirtschaftlichen
erfolg und arbeitsplätze und es wäre
eine weitere option über nrw hinaus und
optionen sind alles in der politik peter
böhme
da hätte sich manch autofahrer heute
morgen noch gern ein fahrrad
herbeigewünscht stau auf der
rheinkniebrücke beim landtag nichts ging
mehr weil der rheinufertunnel in der
stadt wegen technischer probleme
gesperrt war die verkehrswende als der
grünen herzens themen heute die zweite
sitzung der neuen fast dreimal so großen
landtagsfraktionen schwarz grün
schimmert am horizont aber noch halten
sie sich beim thema koalitionspartner
bedeckt
und
erneuerbare energien knackpunkt das sind
themen an dem wir hart verhandeln werden
könnte die ampel lokal ich kenne
schwarz-grün lokal wir werden sehen wir
werden jetzt mit allen reden und
natürlich ist das oberste ziel das
umzusetzen wofür wir gewählt wurden ein
möglicher knackpunkt zwischen cdu und
grünen wäre etwa der ausbau der
windenergie
bisher gilt ein mindestabstand zur
wohnbebauung von 1000 metern die cdu
will daran festhalten
die grünen wollen es ändern oder innere
sicherheit die cdu will bei der polizei
mehr buddy camps und elektroschocker
sowie mehr videoüberwachung die grünen
nicht
oder verkehr aus und neubau von
autobahnen ja oder nein oder autospuren
in den städten umwandeln den radstreifen
auch da drohen diskussionen aber
in der industriepolitik etwa gibt es
viel verbindendes beide wollen die
wirtschaft klimaneutral umbauen
beide bürgerlichen parteien der
politischen mitte verbindet sehr viel
vor allem die idee eine veränderung zu
gestalten eine energiewende die mit
sicherheit die grünen sehr stark
favorisieren werden eben die schwarzen
gleichermaßen unterstützen wenn es
arbeitsplätze auch sichert wenn es
sozial verträglich organisiert wird
sogar ein rechnerisch wäre auch eine
ampel-koalition mit spd grünen und fdp
in düsseldorf möglich aber ist sie auch
realistisch dreier koalition bedeutet
dass man auch
ressorts interessen all diese dinge
durch drei teilen müsste und warum wende
zwei möglichkeit für die grünen bestehen
würde und sie damit auch allein vom
anspruch her wahrscheinlich viel mehr
unterbringen könnten das widerspricht
der möglichkeit auch der logik am ende
ist in drei zu überführt ich halte es
für relativ unwahrscheinlich und was ist
mit kiel wenn es nach wahlgewinner
daniel günther ginge würde er an jamaika
mit grünen und fdp festhalten obwohl er
mit jedem von beiden auch allein
regieren könnte
gibt es eine andere vorgeschichte es
gibt eine geradezu
triumphale begeisterung für jamaika als
neues experiment das sich nicht nur
bewährt hat sondern was wähler auch
gerne fortsetzen wollten das ist sehr
demokratisch als reaktion auf ein
gelungenes modell in düsseldorf sieht es
zunächst nach einem zweierbündnis aus am
nachmittag ein erstes gespräch zur
bewertung der aktuellen politischen lage
wie es hieß danach zwei gleichlautende
statements das war ein angenehmes
offenes und ehrliches gespräch was wir
miteinander führen konnten jetzt gehen
wir damit in die gremien der partei um
alles weitere zu beraten vielen dank
alles im fluss in düsseldorf am mittag
dann auch auf der rheinkniebrücke stau
aufgelöst mal sehen wann das auch im
landtag so kommt schwarz grün wäre eine
politische wende
so jetzt nochmal hanna mit einem sehr
wichtigen thema das uns letztlich alle
betrifft im tarifstreit um bessere lohn
und arbeitsbedingungen für die
beschäftigten im sozial- und
erziehungsberufen gibt es noch immer
keine die kommunalen arbeitgeber die
gewerkschaft verdi und der beamtenbund
dbb verhandeln seit montag es ist die
dritte verhandlungsrunde ein abschluss
der gespräche zeichnet sich allerdings
ab die gewerkschaften fordern für die
rund
330.000 kommunalen beschäftigten neben
höheren löhnen vor allem auch
entlastungen im arbeitsalltag
vor wochen hatte russlands präsident
putin angekündigt das ist russisches gas
nur noch gegen rubel geben soll das
würde allerdings gegen eu sanktionen
verstoßen jetzt rückt der zeitpunkt mehr
an dem auch für deutschland rechnungen
fällig werden und es schließt sich die
frage an wie die zahlungen sanktions
konform gelingen können dann geht man in
frankfurt ganz einfach wird das nicht
oder ja in der tat die deutschen
gasimporteure haben eine knifflige
aufgabe zu lösen gehabt und mussten
dabei lange warten ehe sie von der eu
schriftlich in der hand hatten was genau
sie denn jetzt noch dürfen und was nicht
danach haben sich vermutlich wie beim
energiekonzern enbw die hausjuristen ans
werk gemacht und ein sanktions konformes
zahlungsverfahren entwickelt das
geschäft ist natürlich deutlich
komplizierter geworden weil wir
zahlungen nun über ein konstrukt von
konten abwickeln müssen seit russland
eine bezahlung in rubel verlangt
vereinfacht gesprochen können die
deutschen energiekonzerne weiter in euro
oder dollar bezahlen den umtausch in
rubel übernimmt die russische
gazprombank die nicht mit sanktionen
belegt ist die tücken stecken im detail
aus brüsseler sicht muss mit der
euro/dollar bezahlung so wie es die
verträge vorsehen die transaktion
abgeschlossen sein ein konto in rubel
eröffnen dagegen wäre für die deutschen
versorger ein klarer sanktions verstoß
mit dem jetzt entwickelten prozedere
scheint man vorerst eine lösung gefunden
zu haben ein rest unsicherheit aber
bleibt denn der chef von enbw frank
mastiaux sagte heute noch etwas ob es
dann auf dauer auch läuft werden wir
sehen und große unsicherheit am abend
auch in new york aus furcht vor
drastischen zinserhöhung der notenbank
fed fliehen anleger aus aktien der dow
jones index verliert am abend rund
dreieinhalb prozent
danke frank für diese einordnung
der französische stahlrohr konzern
vallourec hat angekündigt seine beiden
werke in düsseldorf und mülheim an der
ruhr ende 2023 zu schließen insgesamt
seien davon etwa 2400 beschäftigte
betroffen teilte das unternehmen mit
vallourec stellt unter anderem nahtlose
stahlrohre für den öl- und gasmarkt her
seit sieben jahren habe das unternehmen
in deutschland signifikante verluste
geschrieben
zu den lottozahlen an diesem mittwoch
die lauten 18 25 41 43 45 superzahl 6
alle angaben wie immer ohne gewähr
selten passt ein museum so in seine
umgebung wie das was jetzt berlin
geschenkt wurde draußen drogenszene
prostitution die hochbahn drinnen bilder
einer brüchigen und zerbrechenden
gesellschaft draußen die zwanziger jahre
unseres jahrhunderts drinnen die 20er
jahre des letzten bestürzend aktuell ein
berliner sammler hat seinem
lieblingsmaler george grosz ein denkmal
gesetzt ein spektakulärer ort für einen
der früh vor dem schrecken von
nationalsozialismus und krieg warnte
dessen kunst so aktuell wirkt wie lange
nicht mehr christhard läpple nimmt uns
mit
ein traum wird wahr dass die 92 jährige
deutsch amerikanerin diesen augenblick
noch erleben darf die bilder ihres
schwiegervaters cross in einem neuen
privatmuseum in berlin
bilder in einer stadt die ihn vor 90
jahren vertrieben und verjagt hat
lillian cross aus princeton ist extra in
die deutsche heimat zurückgekehrt um das
große comeback im kleinen george grosz
museum zu feiern ein museum in einer
umgebauten tankstelle
[Gelächter]
die liebevoll umgebaute tankstelle von
1956 befindet sich an der hochbahn in
der bülowstraße das viertel rund um den
nollendorfplatz in dem der junge
shawcross die wilden weiber jahre
erlebte die stützen der gesellschaft
beißende zeit kritik an den goldenen
zwanzigern die nur für wenige gold war
knapp 100 jahre alt sein berühmtes werk
zum tanz auf dem vulkan
trotz ist der genaue chronist und
meister maler von babylon berlin ich
würde sagen dass george grosz als einer
der wichtigsten künstler des 20
jahrhunderts bezeichnet werden kann er
hat immer gekämpft gegen die reiche
leute und die russische leute und er war
immer für den kleinen mann
als kleiner mann hat georg ehrenfried
gross so sein geburtsname alles
gezeichnet was ihn interessierte die
frösche erste gehversuche als
elfjähriger zum ersten mal sind die
frühen jahre des malers zu sehen der
gastwirt sohn malte die schrecken des
ersten weltkrieges und warnte in den
20er jahren vor einem heraufziehenden
zweiten weltkrieg france von anfang an
ein hitler gegner bereits 123 malt er
ihn als siegfried der sein folgten den
untergang führt
er kann als das erz und intimfeind
bezeichnet werden weil er einer der
ersten war die hitler öffentlich
angegriffen haben und das in einer zeit
als hitler einen phänomenen münchner
bierkellern war dass andere leute in
berlin gerade künstler überhaupt nicht
interessiert hat was ist heute anders in
unseren 20er jahren es gibt immer noch
eine kernregion
intrusion aber wie man jetzt lebt und
spricht
das ist anders geworden
1933 rettet sich groß in die usa gerät
in vergessenheit er trinkt leidet an
depressionen
erst 1959 rückkehr und tod in seiner
heimatstadt des malers loch sein letztes
bild für lilien cross ist sein comeback
ein glücksfall übrigens auch für uns
das kleine groß museum ganz groß in
berlin das auslandsjournal nimmt uns
jetzt mit in eine stadt zwischen
hoffnung und angst nach aktiv ukraine wo
menschen immer noch in den
u-bahn-schächten leben und andere ihr
leben riskieren um die mitbürger mit
lebensmitteln zu versorgen
gleich hier im haus schon 1 und gegen
0.30 gibt's dann unser heute-journal
update mit nazan bakterien und von uns
allen hier im heute-journal thiemann sie
einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
guten abend heute war es ja sehr heiß in
deutschland und jetzt kommt ein gewitter
tieferen das wird bis morgen abend
bereits schweden erreicht haben von den
gewittern merken wir heute nacht noch
nichts da ist es meist klar und in den
großen städten des ruhrgebietes sinken
die werte nicht unter 20 grad deutlich
angenehmer sind die nachttemperaturen in
bayern bei 10 bis 8 grad und morgen wird
es schweißtreibend zumeist bei
temperaturen von 26 bis 31 grad nur an
der nordsee bleibt es etwas kühler schon
morgen vormittag kann es im emsland mal
das erste gewitter geben sonst aber gibt
es noch viel sonnenschein aber dann wird
es richtig dampf und spätestens am
nachmittag gibt es dann die kräftigen
gewitter im saarland in rheinland pfalz
nordrhein westfalen im westlichen
niedersachsen und zum abend danach aus
dem schwarzwald und aus den alpen heraus
machen sie sich auf unwetter gefasst mit
sturmböen bis 100 kilometer pro stunde
mit starkregen von bis zu 40 liter regen
pro quadratmeter und von hagelkörner die
einen durchmesser von drei zentimetern
haben können diese gewitter werden dann
in der nacht zu freitag abziehen aber
das ist es noch nicht denn es kommt am
freitag schon das nächste gewittertief
heran und das breitet sich dann bis
samstagfrüh hier vor allen dingen über
die mitte und den norden deutschlands
aus da drohen eventuell sogar noch
heftigere gewitter als morgen große
hagelkörner sind zu erwarten just zum
sonntag beruhigt sich die lage guten
abend